no matter how many awards an actor wins
they'll always have a few movies under
their belt that they might not be so
proud of from cheesy action movies to
overly dramatic biopics sometimes an
actor can't help but cross the line into
insane territory often with amazing
results and in some movies it'd be
ridiculous not to give 110 percent are
these the worst examples of overacting
of all time or the best you decide
either way they're all insanely fun to
watch Conair playing a really bad guy is
tricky business go too far and the whole
endeavor winds up coming across as
laughably cartoonish if there's one
actor who can unnerve an audience as a
villain it's John Malkovich he's played
memorably chillin creeps several times
such as his oscar-nominated role as a
would-be presidential assassin in in the
line of fire it went a bit differently
with Conair in this action drama about a
mutiny on a prisoner transport plane
Malkovich plays a master criminal who
pushes his insanity - it's amazing
limits make a move and the bunny gets to
the room at this point the room is
practically legendary it's so filled
with inept performances bizarre acting
choices and completely unnecessary
scenes that it has to be seen to be
believed
how much is it that'll be $18 go keep
the change hi doggie you're my favorite
customer thanks a lot bye that's
primarily the fault of Tommy Wiseau who
wrote directed and produced the room and
also stars as Johnny a San Francisco
finance guy caught up in a doomed love
triangle you are lying I never hit you
you got Tammy partly shop keep in mind
that in all these scenes the writer
director producer and actor all agree
that the performances are spot-on
because they're all the same person one
of them found out about it beat her up
so bad she ended up in a hospital in
Guerrero Street what a story mark spawn
it's hard to blame John Leguizamo for
his scenes in spawn in the film he plays
violator a character whose every move is
ridiculous
[Music]
the characters obviously supposed to be
unpleasant but in the film he makes
clowns even more unpleasant than they
usually are but let's be clear here this
is an evil clown demon in a cheesy
over-the-top 90s comic book movie
anything less from Leguizamo would have
been under acting Mommy Dearest there
are a few amazing things about Faye
Dunaway's over-the-top performance in
Mommy Dearest for starters she was
playing Joan Crawford a real-life Golden
Age Hollywood actress Dunaway's
portrayal of Crawford as a self-absorbed
violent monster ultimately meant that
the would-be drama has since come to be
regarded as a camp comedy classic the
most famous scene sees Dunaway truly
heading into the stratosphere
Crawford really hates wire hangers and
when she finds one in her daughter's
closet well she's a little more than
just disappointed spider-man 3 Sam
Raimi's spider-man 3 gets a bit of a bad
rap but for a good reason after two
stellar films featuring everyone's
favorite web slinger Raimi introduces
some ill-advised plot lines one of which
renders Peter Parker completely
unlikable on the bright side that plot
gives us some of the most memorable
Spidey moments of all time when the
Venom symbiote changes Peters
personality Tobey Maguire goes all-in on
Peters bad-boy montage it's one of the
most unintentionally hilarious parts of
the film or any superhero film for that
matter Peters sports a hit black outfit
and rhythmically shuffles down the
street flashing finger guns at pretty
women
[Music]
he fails miserably and it's all kinds of
fun to watch McGuire is hamming it up
more than any other actor in the trilogy
clearly aware of how ridiculous the
story is to begin with this is for you
spider-man 3 marks the end of Rama's
time with the character but thanks to
McGuire's ridiculous performance it goes
out on an unforgettable note Power
Rangers considering it's based on a
television series that's at its best
when the camp in excess is working in
overdrive 2017 s power rangers film did
a pretty good job of reimagining the
beloved team of teenagers while it never
forgets to be fun it makes every effort
to tell a grounded and more human story
one character seems to be constantly
striking against the grain though it's
not clear if Elizabeth Banks the actress
behind the villainous Rita Repulsa got
the grounded and more human memo her
take on the space which is way over the
top
although yeah it's kind of
understandable considering she's playing
a space witch
you can't say it isn't entertaining it's
just a different kind of entertaining
than the rest of the film there's
certainly a place for performances like
this but even in the context of a Power
Rangers film it's some seriously
laughable stuff The Fifth Element in the
90s actor Gary Oldman came into his own
as a veritable high Prince of overacting
films like true romance and Leon the
professional feature Oldman channeling
an amazing level of energy and to these
more villainous roles bring me everyone
but nothing can match the overacted
hysteria of his performance in the Fifth
Element Oldman plays the film's
antagonist zort before he even starts
overacting you can't help but laugh
thanks to his ridiculous haircut and as
hyper-stylized southern accent slide pan
is adjustable for easy carrying good for
riders and left
strikes down on the fall parts under
technical by x-ray ideal quick discreet
interventions pair that with a truly
bonkers performance and you've got one
of the most peculiar entries in Oldman's
canon it's four songs oh cripes zero
stones zero Chris Oldman has since real
dit in quite a bit and even scored Best
Actor at the 2018 Oscars for darkest
hour but it would be nice to see him in
a zorg style role again someday
[Music]